welcome to this video a blitz challenge
game and the don't they don't be
irritated by the 1400 here because he
has not played a single game of blitz
the splits rating pool he has some
pretty decent five-minute rating so it's
not an entirely uneven match okay and
the favorite on paper but it's not it's
not like he's really rated 1400 ok we
have a nerve and English opening here
playing the so-called cap off variation
very solid way for for black to to play
and he's pushed a quick before yeah I
have all my pieces developed how to play
I can hmm yeah teenage son King edge to
2017 age too so he prevented this
exchange maneuver yeah okay let's
regroup here it also prevents some this
kick against the light like be five and
the night needs to move anyway I'm
trying to prepare here c6 and d5 if
possible okay yeah I'm going to I'm
retreating and kicking it back with c6
yup c6 and then maybe even be five yeah
if I take on d5
he probably recapture cd5 we had stuff
bad better do that come on and then be
five looks that looks like a good way to
generate to generate some some counter
play maybe even Knight b6 to increase
the pressure on the sea for porn okay
maybe you can play a4a for him Jim the
night on g6 is mostly looking at squares
that is not controlling often the idea
to bring it over here is to support in
five so that you can better play d 5 now
if i take here take this 6 here now come
on I need to get rid of this night this
is just too annoying okay so taking here
Knight f6 mm-hmm not sure
what I'm complicated not so easy to play
and I can take and play for Andy five
this maybe I come on let's let's get
some activity in the center going that
should be really too bad oh ok I was
expecting 95 but i can get the Queen to
F forum this is probably what I should
do the Queen on f4 looks like a good
like a good active piece it also
prepares hmm h5 ok he wants to go here
probably what about h5 here come on h5
g5 night h7 and both pawns are hanging
ocular Queen FIA play squinty tool i
guess so wow wow it looks like a very we
King side but maybe I cannot exploit it
take it
hmm
well very complicated may be here queen
is still Queen d2 actually hmm my
probably not a good move let's see yeah
I thought I can take here now let's do
that I if it takes you can take on d5
night maybe not a 5 rook everyone I've
got Queen III check but this fields I
know this feels a bit shaky others you
can also just take on non c6 now and
maybe try try to try to promote the sit
bone I mean okay is king but am I really
having a dangerous attack here I don't
don't know even look I have one is
possible look I have 123 check okay
yeah can I not I can go here maybe here
intending to take on age three yeah take
here takes on g3 knight takes Bishop
takes the tick on d5 maybe I take g3 is
probably nonsense now well it's very
difficult technically a very difficult
so I'm a pawn up but the position is not
clear at all go here b5 of 95 I know I
the pants but I'm activating malukas
well yeah still a c6 it's probably good
maybe this is good for white it's
possible time warning
okay I'm trying for 9am for you very
quickly it took them that was lucky
check yeah i think i'm i'm able to to
get this in yeah and with two connected
pawns shouldn't be a win check no no we
have seven whoops check I can take wow
what am I doing here let's still win ok
check well yeah it said sometimes
completely crazy stuff happens if you
got little time and I just nervous white
resins incoming challenge yeah I'm going
for a rematch and yeah I've got a little
time on my hands but I want to give him
this rematch so I'm not doing a big
recap of this game so thanks for
watching